hello in playmatch
almost 6 000. that's what i've ever done
in my lifetime on ranked offline online
that's everything holy cow all right
ladies that's here we go put your bets
in in the chat here for the channel
points who do you think is going to take
it saudi arabia
versus georgia devil rocky versus ultra
instinct potato a king mirror match
we'll get some wrestling hey ladies and
lads for who is going to meet complain
in that winner's finals
let's go it's going to be very
interesting to see they're both looking
the man in the mirror at a minute to see
each other you're not spiderman members
pointing at each other
all right here we go
devil rocky with that ten win streak
okay bear can't hit back once get things
started yeah okay running powerbomb nice
push him towards the wall
nice lock on the low
oh oh
giant swing oh let's go that was it that
is so tight
oh my god flip was that i nearly threw
up
what was that
i wonder if that's the actual set up
there because that was clean
yeah oh nice he actually did something
there not the best combo nice oaky yes
that was guaranteed that low kick and
goes for the 43
ddt
nice i actually done a little bit of
research about ddt you know where that
move actually came from the name actual
real wrestling i tell her
i want to know now it's something like
to do with insecticide like jake the
snake or something
and it kills them yeah it's something
like that weird like that
nice
okay
it was a good start there for double
rocky to start off that first round but
i'll try to potato he managed to bring
it back the throw breaks are on point
now as well
okay he ain't breaking giant swings yeah
well like he said jack with king is a
mix up on the frozen it actually does
sometimes look like a one plus two throw
so it says it's hard you can't break the
movie king that's that's the thing is
this
sometimes it's just nice this is crazy
right now man with how many saudi
arabians were having this top eight is
it gonna be a non-saudi in that uh in
that winner's finals why it may have a
saudi goo like in a minute that's
everyone in the loser
this is such a good performance here
from ultron so like i said he picks his
shot so wisely yeah he's so fundamental
he knows when to throw and he knows when
to go for the post and here we go nice
break
and guess whoa there you go side step
two this is going to be it keeps the
combo nice and simple three rounds
straight there
damn ultra instinct potato man
yeah i mean this is what we're used to
seeing this is actually what we're used
to seeing from ultra potato when he when
he's on point he sometimes is
unstoppable like you know what i mean it
sometimes could just be unstoppable i
feel like he's in the he's in the mode
if you're playing against king again
breaking giant swings man it's not the
best situation for you i want to know
what happened with that forward one plus
four where it looked like it crossed
behind him and
i i really wonder if that was some some
technology i know i i definitely believe
that was some georgian technology
from altering the potato and it looked
like the the back 10 4 was was
guaranteed yeah that was definitely that
king didn't know what was going on right
he yeah he had no clue i i had no clue
he was like how do i block this is it
can i block can i yeah but i wonder
what's he gonna go for now does he go to
the um you can't even really comfortably
go to forgotten rome because even though
you have the uh that's that's the
throwback i mean your opponent has the
same advantage as well right so what do
you do here that is a very big risk to
go for the forgotten realm now you got
to be confident in yourself there that
you know that you're gonna get to that
we're we've already seen a world record
um for the forgotten realm like getting
to the bottom floor
he needs to run that world record that
speed run on that if you're gonna use it
okay no keeps it mission madojo okay i
respect it
yeah look like he chose the stage as
well right yeah he did yeah okay
interesting
just probably waiting some down time
just to kind of think about what you
what you could do what you and what
changes he needs to make
um okay it'll be interesting to see
all right let's go man second game
incoming auctions potato has all of the
momentum nice so he's he's already
looking like he's using those jabs just
to kind of stop um on straight into
potato getting something started
okay oh man oh yo
breaking throws man well he's mixing are
you coming playing against the king
player like alternatives over there and
not be breaking throws it's hard to be
he's mixing them up really well he's
that's the first time i've seen the
two-throw
okay guess i can't hit they've got
people's elbow
down there
go to the shaft that was that was very
unfortunate it looked like it would have
punished but i guess king's hurt box on
that
yeah nice oh harry is he gonna get
something can he kill though the wall's
there
no oh oh kill now
oh my god
we need to really run on that one that
was insane
left right and center can you see the
var on that one
i need to see it
damn that was so unfortunate for devil
rocky there yeah i really feel like he
needed that round too bubsy because of
the last match was so dominant for
entrance potato and double rocky he's
not looking so good now
yeah i hope that doesn't dishearten him
it's definitely man okay just evading
everything in a minute okay back once i
get a count hit could have duck there
nice block oh that was the right punish
but he didn't get it though it's a
little bit too slow it looks like he did
hesitate a little bit on the punish
yeah
oh he's really he wants that backbone
punished but he's not just a little bit
late on it yeah oh no what are we gonna
go for now oh are we gonna see it uh are
we gonna see it no we didn't uh uh it's
still gonna come out
the damage all right ladies and gents
ultra in sick potato from georgia on set
points and move to winners finals
against complain looking very impressive
okay are we going to see a rolling death
cradle nope we're going to go for the
russian deck sweep
instead now an armbar
oh yeah what's the okay okay nice in the
back
okay now this is what i want to see just
use your that's it use that momentum
okay using those jabs
nice can't hit there
dog tommy's going to make a comeback
here ultra is the potato taking it to
the wall now rage available needs to be
very careful nice with punished on the
down back too
yeah
all right he's still awake he's not
sleeping at the wheel just yet
yeah but he's going to need a reverse
repair man i'm telling you all
he knows when to pick his shots he knows
when to go for the throws and he's
mixing it up hey now bubsy
did he just he's giving him back the
same movie product he just ate
he just done the same change this isn't
messy
and the punishment not quite there as
well good shining was in no break yeah
that was this oh just giant sings him
out of his throat attempt to look like
it looked like he was going for a crash
mix up throw doesn't tech that is huge
damages ian does have rage available can
make a comeback
okay try to go for that shot get account
here and gets easter jabs this is last
chance saloon here and goes to the
upward free
taking it yeah that is gonna be it ultra
into potato gonna take it over double
rocky two oh man it just looked like
devil rocky was so uncomfortable the way
that the way that um the ultra